you have to get started once you get
started you'll continue hi steve kaufman
here again
and today i want to talk to you about my
advice for a first-time language learner
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast
service please leave a comment
so
uh the reason i want to talk about this
is i have a brother an older brother uh
and he lives in windsor ontario not far
from toronto i went to visit him he's
kind of
you know
bed bound bedridden
uh so i want to go there i wanted to go
there and cheer him up
and
give him things to do because he's in
the bed like he he does exercises to try
to get you know strengthen his muscles
but for a variety of reasons that i
won't get into it's going to be a bit of
a chore for him he's going to take him a
while before he gradually gets you know
more mobile
so i said okay you know
got to get the brain moving as well so i
bought him an ipad and i said first of
all you should do scrabble because as
kids we used to love playing scrabble
and the great thing about doing scrabble
on the ipad which my wife does i don't
do
is that the other person like you're
playing against the computer the
computer puts a word out right away so
you don't have to wait the worst thing
in scrabble to me was
i was fairly quick at putting out a word
and then it for if i had one opponent
opponent or two opponents it would take
forever before i had a turn again
whereas if you play with the computer
it's instant which is kind of fun so i
got my brother onto scrabble and i also
said you should learn a language which
language you want to learn spanish okay
get on link and learn spanish
so okay whatever he wasn't tremendously
motivated
but at some level he would like to learn
spanish he does speak french you know
grew up montreal and
so
uh anyway he calls me the other day and
he says steve i have a real problem
in using link
oh okay so i thought maybe it was
something with our functionality and so
forth
and he said no it's like
all these words i forget them
so these spanish words as soon as i
learn something look it up i've
forgotten it
and i thought to myself
you know how many people
become disappointed or frustrated
because they can't remember things
to me it's obvious that i'm not going to
remember i have to see the words
10 times and then there are words that i
know and then i'll then i'll forget them
again in persian or arabic
so i thought to myself you know
there are so many people who at some
level would like to learn a language
and
you know they just never get anywhere so
these are not the keeners the people who
know what they want to do in language
who who say understand link or who like
link or don't like link but they know
that they want to learn a language and
they know what they have to do
but the vast majority of people don't
the vast majority of people may even go
to a bookstore and buy a book on
language learning and never do much so i
would like to suggest three bits of
advice for someone who is
not kind of a an experienced language
learner or maybe trying to learn their
first language language the first thing
is
just get started there are
expressions that exist in many languages
the gist of which is the first step is
the job half done
you know it doesn't matter whether it's
you know i'm
right now i'm power washing my deck okay
you have to get started once you get
started you'll continue yeah i got to
finish the deck but as long as i look at
it and don't do anything
it's not going to happen
so the first thing is if you'll just get
started
just get started and i thought again
with my brother i finally got him to get
started okay get started the second
thing is try to create a habit
i mean we all know that if we haven't
been exercising for a while and then we
go to the gym the first two or three
sessions are difficult
but if we are able to create a habit
where we go to the gym regularly three
times a week four times a week
we start to feel unhappy if we haven't
had that exercise because we've created
a habit at different levels both you
know psychologically and physically
we've developed this this this
dependence this need for that regular
activity and i feel that way about my
language learning if i let too many days
go by where i haven't
you know spent time with the language
that i'm learning it bothers me so i
have that habit for better or for worse
but if you can create a habit
that will drive you to keep going
so first of all get started
second of all try to create a habit
to do certain things that's why we have
so many things at linked like you know
maintaining your streak or following
your statistics because sometimes you
need that kind of
you know little nudge all the time to
keep you going
because
if you put in the time you will improve
that gets back to the the statement that
i heard from this director of the
san diego
university language department who said
there's only two things that matter in
language learning the attitude of the
learner and the time you put in
so you've got to put in the time you've
got to keep going so whatever it takes
to develop a habit so that you keep
going the third thing is and if i expand
from you know the attitude of the
learner and the time you put in to this
formula
from cat olam or lomkato hungarian
polyglot
she had this equation which basically
was sort of the time you put in
and the attitude
divided by
negativity frustration inhibition fear
all of the negative stuff so you have to
put in the time you have to have a
positive attitude you have to want to
learn you have to think you can learn
but you have to minimize the negative
stuff so
if you forget that's normal
don't expect to remember
recognize that if you keep putting the
time putting the time in
if you keep
a positive attitude you will learn and i
think very often the beginner language
learner thinks that they have to learn
these rules and if they don't remember
the rules then they won't learn the
language or they've been added for
several months and they can still can't
speak and so they this negativity comes
in i still can't do anything i'm no good
and yet
you know the the beginner language
learner has to understand that with
enough exposure to the language if you
can develop a habit first of all you
have to get started and then you develop
this habit that you are regularly
listening and reading to and do whatever
you like to do if it's duolingo
i'm not gonna you know personally i
prefer working with link but
as i've said many times you know people
should do what they want to do so that
they enjoy it but stay with it keep
doing it
and when you encounter difficulties and
i think i keep saying it and yet it's so
important for beginner language learners
to realize you get it wrong it doesn't
matter you can't remember it doesn't
matter you don't understand it doesn't
matter nothing matters
accept the fact that you maintain a
positive attitude
believe that you will eventually get
there and keep on putting in the time
and
in order to keep on putting in the time
you may have to set up
some routine
that helps you create this habit
so i this is kind of what i told my
brother
and i thought to myself you know it's
not just my brother it's many people who
never who at some level would like to be
fluent in another language
would like to be
good language learners think they aren't
good language learners and therefore
they end up
not achieving very much so i hope that's
helpful to
those of you and maybe
people who listen to me are all good
language learners but maybe some of your
friends are not so i hope that's helpful
thanks
and oh and i think i'll leave you with
two videos uh
from uh before where i talk about being
a lazy language learner and i also talk
about the three keys to language
learning success
thanks for listening bye for now